le retour des avions bleu et blanc dans
le ciel tour on joue avec l'allègement
des restrictions l'aéroport relance deux
destinations pour l'instant marseille et
porto est les vols ne sont pas pleins
mais de nombreux franco portugais en
profite pour revoir leur famille et amis
à condition de respecter certaines
règles et notamment une 14ème à
l'arrivée
audrey champigny 12h53 vol pour porto a
annoncé au départ de tours dans un peu
moins d'une heure
dans la file des passagers daniel est
impatient de revoir sa famille et ses
amis après cinq mois dans ses mains le
précieux sésame
un test pcr négatif en fait il faut
prendre un billet en même temps
surprendre le test pour le coc vide
malheureusement faute chanson il faut
élever la voix pour envoyer dans
l'europe car avant de passer les douanes
et d'embarquer un premier contrôle est
effectué en même temps que la
vérification des papiers d'identité et
du billet d'avion et pour certains c'est
la douche froide
hélas les buts 72 heures avant le départ
qui est très dense à l'ombre du coup je
suis désolé madame mai
on va pouvoir faire partie parce que tu
es super talent a t il fait trop tôt
imagine que vous êtes un peu déçu quand
même parce que du coup je suis pas ce
que je vais payer d'un voyage et ne peut
pas passer ma famille combattants et là
avec la limite des 10 km tomber les vols
pour la france et l'europe sont de
nouveau autorisés depuis tour
pour l'instant seule une rotation par
semaine pour marseille et porto
une reprise en douceur qui relance un
peu l'activité de l'aéroport du val de
loire
actuellement seulement à 21,22 en
fonction des programmes des animaux mais
assez loin du trafic du trafiquant
d'armes qui connaîtront en 2009 ou début
2010 on avait des journées des journées
avec dans quelques mois en fonction des
restrictions sanitaires
les vols pour londres dublin ou encore
marrakech devrait être de nouveau
ouverts à la réservation
seul bémol la 14ème obligatoire dans
tous les pays d'europe